leaders need to model behavior um
like parents need to model behavior um
so for example i'll give you you know a
company says you know we believe in
integrity and always telling the truth
and then the phone rings and you know uh
an assistant picks up the phone and and
the executive says tell him i'm not in
you know well congratulations you've
just sanctioned lying you know um
and so it's one thing to write it on the
wall it's another thing to actually
practice the thing that's written on the
wall um so modeling the behavior is
absolutely essential
because your actions will speak much
louder than your words
and
the stories do matter
stories are much more powerful than
statistics
what did stalin
he
say
quoting stalin
um
uh the death of one man
is a uh the
uh the death of one man is a tragedy the
death of a million is a statistic
interesting i think he said it the other
way around the death of a million men
are statistics and one of them is a
tragedy and i'll give you a real life
example um just to just to put it into
into
so let's let's say something like okay
so um
uh
kovid ravaged
the world
some would argue expectedly some would
argue unexpectedly but it happened
and over the course of
just over a year
600 000 people in the united states
alone have lost their lives
many
women uh
children and fathers and mothers and and
families destroyed by this by this this
horrible uh virus
okay that's true right
here's story number two um i know this
young woman who lives in northern
southern california her name is kami
yoder
kami was driving home from work one day
and she turned the corner and came upon
a car accident that had just happened
the ambulance hadn't arrived yet
a
17 year old driver
accidentally hit an 18 year old
pedestrian with her car
the girl was lying on this on the street
one of her legs at an
uncomfortable angle
a 90 degree angle
cami pulled over her car got out thank
goodness she actually knows basic uh
first aid she performed cpr on the young
girl to keep her alive until the the
paramedics arrived
eventually the paramedics came they took
over from kami and they took the girl to
the hospital
a couple of days later
cammy was curious what had happened to
her and she
went on the the the blotter she went on
online and found out that the young girl
had actually died
which was more powerful to you the death
of six hundred thousand people or the
death of one young girl in california
and the second one gave you goosebumps
the first one didn't and that's the
point which is what's the difference
between five hundred thousand people
dead or six hundred thousand people the
six hundred fifty thousand people did it
emotionally moves us zero
um but when you tell the story of a
person
who is an example
of what happens if we tell the story of
one death of kovid and how it's affected
that family the emotional impact is
vastly more powerful than simply
relaying statistics and numbers and so
yes i do believe that part of being a
good leader is not just the intent but
part of the leadership is the ability to
communicate
those things those things i think are
inextricably linked and learning how to
tell a story quite frankly that captures
the value of your work because people
can relay those stories
much easier than they can relay or
remember the statistics
throughout the organization throughout
the organization story gets passed down
past sometimes
generations generationally and and
great organizations like great cultures
have a myth
you know um there there's stories that
have been passed down generations in in
nations about the founding you know the
marine corps celebrates their birthday
every year
um there's debate whether that's
actually even their birthday or not it
doesn't even matter
right um and and it becomes part of the
culture these stories becoming green you
know george washington and the cherry
tree yeah was it a cherry tree yeah um
uh
uh like the they become ingrained in the
fabric of the of the nation
so too do they become ingrained in the
fabric of the company and like religion
like anything it's the stories
that captured the morals and values much
better than just writing them on the
wall